اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسونه عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
تعزيزاتنا امنيه مشدده في محيط محكمه
منهات قبيل مثول ترامب امام قاضي المحكمه
[موسيقى]
فنلندا تنضم رسميا للناتو واشنطن تتهم
موسكو بالعداء وتحملها مسؤوليه التوسع
الحلف
سوف ينظم العلاقه بما يضمن التوزيع العادل
للثروه على كل الموصل العراق يقول ان
الاتفاق النفطي مع اربيل مؤقت حتى اقرار
الموازنه العامه
اذن مشاهدينا نبدا هذه النشره الخامسه من
الولايات المتحده وبالتحديد من نيويورك
حيث يستعد الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب للمثول امام المحكمه اليوم وسط
تعزيزات امنيه مشدده وفق اعلام امريكي
رحلته ترامب بدات بمغادره منزله في بالم
بيتش وصولا الى برج ترامب في منهات
بنيويورك بعدها سيصل ترامب الى محكمه
منهات حيث سيواجهه الادعاء في اول لائحه
اتهام لرئيس امريكي سابق عند الساعه
الثانيه وخمسه عشره دقيقه بالتوقيت المحلي
اي الثامنه عشره والربع بتوقيت جرينتش بعد
الانتهاء سيغادر ترامب نيويورك عائدا الى
فلوريدا وتحديدا الى مقره هناك سيعقد
مؤتمرا صحفيا عند الساعه الثامنه وخمسه
عشره دقيقه اي عند منتصف الليل بتوقيت
جرينتش واخر التصريحات تشير الى ان ترامب
يطالب بتغيير موقع المحاكمه وبنقلها الى
ستاتيند جنوب منهاتم
[تصفيق]
هذا وتتجه انظار العالم الى هذه المحكمه
محكمه منهاتن بنيويورك حيث يستمع ترامب
الى لائحه اتهامه في قضيه دفع اموال
لممثله اباحيه مقابل صمتها طبعا ابانا
انتخابات الرئاسه في 2016 بطوله ترامب
امام المحكمه يصلح ان يطلق عليه بمحاكمه
القرن فهو حدث تاريخي هو حدث غير مسبوق
لرئيس امريكي
ما هي الخطوه القانونيه التاليه بعد اتهام
ترامب
سيصطحب جهاز الخدمه السريه ترامب من برجه
في نيويورك الى محكمه منهاتن
كالعاده ومثل اي متهم في نيويورك سيخضع
ترامب لاجراءات الحجز المعتاده عبر اخذ
بصماته والتقاط صورته والتي قد تؤدي
لواحده من اشهر الصور الجنائيه في العصر
الحديث بعد استماع ترامب لتهاماته سيتمكن
من تقديم التماس وفقا لوزاره العدل سيجري
ممثل الادعاء العام ومحام ترامب مفاوضات
حول شروط الافراج مثل قيود السفر او الحجز
في المنزل
محامي ترامب اكدوا انه لن يتم تصفيده كما
سيدفع امام المحكمه بانه غير مذنب
يواجه اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال في
مجال الاعمال
على كل المزيد معنا من امام محكمه منهات
الجنائيه مدير مكتب العربيه في نيويورك
طلال الحاج اهلا بك طلال اسمح لي ان ابدا
بالعواجل التي استمعنا اليها هناك حديث
انه ترامب يطالب بتغيير مكان المحاكمه
خبرنا اكثر
نعم هذا طلبه منذ بضعه ايام لانه يعتقد
انه لا يمكن اختيار لجنه محلفين محايده
هنا في نيويورك كما تعرفين نيويورك هي
قاعه الديمقراطيين في الولايات المتحده
ومن اكثر
يعني في الانتخابات في عام 2016 وكذلك في
انتخابات 2020 حصل على سته عشر في المئه
من الاصوات هنا في هذه الولايه وعشرين في
المئه في عام 2020 لذلك ترامب يعتقد ان
لديه فرصه اكبر في الحصول على
قرار من لجنه المحلفين اذا كانت بعيده عن
نيويورك ولكن المكان المطروح هو ايضا
تابعه الى نيويورك
والمحكمه حتى هذه اللحظه لا تعير اهتماما
لهذه المطالب لانه حتى هذه اللحظه تعتبر
هذه المحكمه عادله والقاضيه عاجل وسمعته
طيبه
تكرار مثل هذه الدعوات من قبل ترامب
الى حد كبير اذا تكرار مثل هذه التصريحات
او المطالب لم تفيدوا بهذه نحن امام قائم
نعرف تفاصيله طلال
نعم هو سيقلب الى هنا الساعه السادسه عشر
بتوقيت جرينتش سيدخل وطلب ان يتحدث الى
الصحافه داخل المحكمه عند دخوله وكذلك بعد
خروجه من الجلسه الاتهامات
الشرطه السريه وشرطه نيويورك رفضت ذلك ولم
يسمح بالكاميرات داخل قاعه المحكمه سوى
القاضي سمح بخمسه شركات اعلاميه بارسال
مصورين فوتوغرافيين لالتقاط صور لا فيديو
لدقائق معدوده في بدايه جلسه الاعلان عن
التهم اما تفاصيل التهم
هناك تقارير تم تداولها بان القاضي سيعلن
عنها البارحه ولكن لم يحدث شيء من هذا
القبيل ويبدو انه ينوي الاعلان عنها
الساعه الثامنه عشر والربع بتوقيت جرينتش
اليوم عندما يقتل ترامب امامه
سياتي الى المحكمه في موكب من السيارات
يضم احد ى عشر سياره
فيما يتعلق بالتهم لن يكون هناك نقل مباشر
لهذه المحاكمه كيف او ما طبيعه المعلومات
التي ستصل للناس بهذا الاطار
تهم تخرج من المحكمه ستكون في سجل رسمي
وسيمنح رقم متهم اذا اخذوا له صور وهذا
الامر لم يحسم بعد في المفاوضات بين
المحامين ودعاء اذا اخذت صور سيوضع هذا
الرقم على على صوره واذا تم تسريبها
تسريبها من هذه المحكمه فالعالم كله في
انتظار مثل هذه الصور ولكن
التهم سوف يعرض القاضي على ترامب قراءتها
داخل الجلسه ولكن اعتقد ان ترامبلين يقبل
بذلك وسيدعي البراءه الكامله من هذه التهم
ولكنها ستعلن حاله انتهاء هذه الجلسه
وسنعرف ما هي الاربعه وثلاثين 34 تهمه
الموجهه اليك كما نفهم الان
وسيتجه الى
[موسيقى]
مره حيث يقتل لال قاء خطاب الليله في تمام
الساعه الثانيه عشر او ثاني عشر والربع
بتوقيت جرينش ليلا طلال الاجواء المحيطه
خبرنا ولو تتحرك الكاميرا سريعا اذا امكن
[موسيقى]
هناك تجمعات داخل الحديقه التي نقف امامها
من المتظاهرين
وقسمها رجال الشرطه الى جزئين جزء
لابوسان الاخر لمناوي ترامب وكانت هناك
مناوشات صباح اليوم بين الطرفين ولكن نفهم
ان الشرطه او راينا الشرطه لانه وقف
امامهم
فصلوا بين الجزئين بالرغم من تبادل او
تلاسم اعضاء هذه المظاهرات هذه المظاهرات
المفروض ان تبدا الساعه الثانيه عشر
بتوقيت جرينتش لذلك هي في بدايتها
وسترتفع الاعداد ولكن تريني رجال الشرطه
بجاكيتات الزرقاء يقفون على اهبه
الاستعداد للفصل بين الطرفين
والشرطه كثيره هنا جدا جدا جدا وفي شوارع
في في مركبات وحافلات ينتظرون وقوع اي
اضطرابات للقدوم الى هنا وشركات الاعلام
التي نقف هنا معها جميعها
جاءت باقناعتي من كل انحاء العالم
الملايين يتابعون هذا اليوم نعم من امام
محكمه من هاتن الجنائيه كان معنا مدير
مكتب العربيه في نيويورك طلال الحاج شكرا
جزيلا لك
هذا هو لم يتوقف ترامب عن هجومه وعن وعيده
ترامب قال انه سيتم توجيه الاتهام اليه في
34 تهمه متهما المدعي العام في منهات الفن
براد بتسريب رائحه الاتهام لوسائل الاعلام
كما اشار الرئيس الامريكي السابق لانه لا
توجد تغييرات او مفاجات وانه غير مذنب
مؤكدا ايضا انه يجب توجيه لائحه الاتهام
الى المدعي العام نفسه حيث تسربت محتويات
لوائح الاتهام الى الصحافه
مع استمرار هجوم ترامب على الادعاء العام
ربما تلجا المحكمه لاسكات الرئيس السابق
من خلال اصدار امر حضر النشر في هذه
القضيه طبعا هذه الخطوه اذا ما قررها
القاضي اخوان مارشنسي تمنع ترامب وستمنع
محاميه من التحدث عالمنا عن هذه القضيه
طبعا خارج جدران المحكمه المنع اذا ما تم
يعني ان ترامب لن يكون قادر على نشر ما
يريد على منصته للتواصل الاجتماعي التروس
التي يستخدمها للتواصل مع الملايين من
انصاره كانت ترامب استغل هذه المنصه منصه
التروس في الايام الماضيه طبعا انتقاد
لاذع للمدعي العام في منهات
والقاضيه ايضا نمرشن وحذر بما اسماه
بالموت وايضا الدمار اذا وجهت اليه تهمه
ترامب اعتبر ان امريكا في طريقها الى
الجحيم ويخطط ترامب لالقاء خطاب اذا كما
ذكر مراسلنا بعد ساعات من مثولها امام
المحكمه لكن امر حظر النشر قد يفسد هذه
الخطه في التي يقول البعض انها محاوله
لاستغلال الازمه السياسيه طبعا هذا كله
بحسب مراقبين بعض المحامين المؤيدين لامر
حظر النشر يرون ان الادعاء في القضيه ليس
مشهدا عاما في حين يرفض فريق ترامب
القانوني هذه الخطوه يعتبرها انتهاك للحق
في التعبير عن الراي
على كل المزيد معنا من واشنطن دكتور ادمون
غريب الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك
دكتور بدايه قراءه في المشهد من متابعتك
للتطورات ما الذي تراه
اولا
قبل لحظات هذه هذا حدث عالمي الى حد ما
والعالم انظار العالم كلها اليوم تركز على
هذه القضيه على الرغم من ان هناك الكثير
من القضايا الاخرى التي ربما تحتاج الى
التركيز عليها اكثر ان كانت بسائل الحروب
وان كانت القضايا الوضع الاقتصادي ارتفاع
نسبه الجريمه ولكن فعلا هذه قضيه غير
مسبوقه من ناحيه اخرى اول مره نرى رئيس
امريكي يحاكم
توجه اتهامات له ما تفضلت واشرت اليه في
النهايه نقطه مهمه جدا ومثيره لان هذه
ليست فقط اذا تمت فعلا محاوله لما يسمى
جاج اوردر او لاسمارت لمنع ترامب من
التحدث عن هذه القضيه ايضا سيكون ستكون
فيها نوع من الانتهاك لاول مره
ولمحاوله للتاثير على نتائج الانتخابات
لان ترامب سيبقى مرشحا
للرئاسه ما لم يدان وحتى لو ادين
فلن يمنع لن تكون هناك اي قوانين تمنعه من
ترشيح نفسه وبالتالي فان ترامب عند اذا
سيقول ان هذه محاوله للتاثير على
الانتخابات وطبعا هناك عدد كبير من
القانونيين الذين يثيروا اسئله حول هذا
الموقف ولكن ايضا
دكتور هي الفكره
بخطابه النار دائما وانتقاداته وخاصه
المخاوف بان يعود ويحرض الشارع ليتحرك
بطريقه شهدناها سابقا
فعلا هذه النقطه
الرجل مشاكس مقاتل شرس وهو يحاول ايضا
الاستغلال هذا الوضع لصالحه بان يقول بان
المدعي العام الى حدا ما كل شيء مسيس هذه
الايام في الولايات المتحده وهذه القضيه
هي ايضا من القضايا التي تمت الشيشه لان
المدعي العام براج عندما رشح نفسه لهذا
المنصب قال بانه احدى الوعود التي قدمها
لناخب لانه سيلاحق ترامب وسيجلبه الى
المحكمه اذا كان هو يستهدف ترامب حتى قبل
ان تكون هناك ولكنه عندما وصل قال في
البدايه انه ان هذه القضيه قضيه دفع اموال
للحفاظ على صمت
الممثله الاباحيه
ليست قضيه يعني يمكن بحاجه لمتابعتها خاصه
ان المدعي العام السابق والم دعي المحكمه
الفدراليه لم تتابعها ولكنه
سننتظر لائحه الاتهام ونرى على ماذا تعتمد
وشهري الوثائق اللي عم بيحكوا عنها اضافه
انه في محاكم اخرى تنتظر ترامب على كل من
واشنطن دكتور رائد الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لك
ومشاهدينا في تداعيات محاكمه ترامب ايضا
ما هي سيناريوهات المحتمله السياسيا طبعا
بعد توجيه هذا الاتهام سيكون ترامب والذي
يبلغ من العمر 76 عاما في ورطه كاول رئيس
سابق او في المنصب يوجه اليه الاتهام
بارتكاب جنايه ومع عدم معرفه التهم
بالتحديد الموجهه للترامب من الصعب طبعا
التكهن ان كانت الادانه المحتمله ستؤدي
الى الحكم بالسجن على رئيس امريكي السابق
مع ذلك يعتقد بان التهم التي ستوجه الى
ترامبس تشمل الاحتيال التجاري ستشمل
انتهاكات متعلقه بتمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه ولكن من غير الواضح ان كانت من
جرائم الجنايات والتي طبعا تؤدي الى عقوبه
السجن المحتمله توقيت الازمه هو الاسواق
طبعا ياتي ايضا على اعتاب انتخابات يامل
ترامب في من خلالها الى العوده الى البيت
الابيض سيواصل ترامب بالتاكيد مسعاه لخوض
الانتخابات حتى في حال مواجهته تهما
جنائيه فلا يوجد اي بند في الدستور
الامريكي يمنعه من الترشح للرئاسه حتى في
حال مواجهته التهم
وفي سبيل البحث عن مخرج للورطه التي وجدت
نفسه فيها لجا الى تعيين المحاميه
كاخر المنضمين الى فريقه القانوني
المحامي تود بلانش اخر المنضمين الى فريق
الدفاع الترام قبل ساعات فقط من محاكمته
وهو مدعي فيدرالي سابق يتمتع بخبره واسعه
في قضايا ولايه نيويورك
عمل كمساعد المدعي العام للولايات المتحده
في المنطقه الجنوبيه بنيويورك لما يقرب من
عقد
كما اشرف بلانش على قضايا ذوي الياقات
البيضاء ويتمتع بسمعه كبيره كمدافع عدواني
ويتمتع ايضا بشبكه علاقات واسعه بالفريق
القانوني لدونالد ترامب
ومن الشخصيات التي مثلها بلانش رئيس حمله
ترامب السابق بورس ايبشتاين بعد ان
واجهتهمه الاحتيال في عام 2019
بالاضافه الى رجل الاعمال اجر فرومن الذي
واجهتهما اختلاف مساهمه ماليه في عام 2021
والمزيد معنا من واشنطن عبر سكايب بشار
جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد
بشار اسمحلي ان ابدا بما انتهينا به وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بتعيين محامي جديد ماذا يقول
هذا القرار في اللحظات الاخيره عن موقف
ترامبو وحالته الان
معروف عن الترامب خبره بالتعامل مع القضاء
والاعلام
والتوقيت هو يريد به حسب ما وصف اضافه قوه
ناريه لفريق موجود اصلا العبره هي في
اختيار شخصيه لديها مصداقيه عاليه في دور
المحاماه هذه المصداقيه التي تغيب عن طرف
اخر مثل كون الذي تم نزع رخصه مزاوله
المهنه بسبب كذبه المتكرر هذا يظهر على
الاقل من وجهه نظر الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه
التي يخطط لها الرئيس ترامب والفريق بانه
مدرك لتفاصيل تتعلق بخصوصيه نيويورك وخاصه
خصوصيه منهات وبشكل اكثر تحديدا التعامل
مع الاسلوب الروتيني الذي جرت عليه العاده
فيما يتعلق في التعامل مع القضايا
المتخصصه
بشخصيات العامه ولكن اللجوء الى هذه
الخطوه هل هو بديل عن مطالبات سابقا بنقل
المحاكمه الى منطقه اخرى وان كانت في
منهات ايضا جنوبها
لا يوجد تناقض بين الموضوعين والقضيه
الخاصه في النقل من منهات بسبب انك هيئه
محلفين وهذا مثل الامريكي معروف بانك
تستطيع بهيئه محلفين ان تدين حتى ساندويتش
بمعنى وهذا طبعا من الشيء الذي يعتبر يعني
كتندر ولكن يشير الى خطوره اختيار محلفين
اذا كانت اهوائهم السياسيه او لديهم اي
اشتباك حتى هذا قانونا في امريكا معروف
وحتى عرفا انه لا يجوز لهيئه المحلفين ان
تكون على صله لا بالمتهم ولا حتى باي قضيه
لو كانت من معارفهم او عائلاتهم ذات صله
بما يتم طرحه فما بالك ان جاد على ذلك
قضيه القاضي القاضي من المعروف انه لا يحب
ترامب وهذا ايضا مثبت وقضيه من هاتم بحد
ذاتها هي منطقه معاديه لترامب وجدنا كيف
انها معاديه حتى
خرجوا بالتظاهر السلمي بدات قبل قليل
وعندما يتم
على الاقل بانها اقل عداء واقل ارتباطا
بالحزب الديمقراطي ولكن رغم ما ذكرته يقال
بانه هذه المحاكمه تحديدا هي اقل المشاكل
اذا مصحه تعبير من التحقيقات الاخرى اعتقد
اربعه هناك تنتظر ترامب ايضا
لن يستطيع ام انه سيستطيع بذكائه كما
تعلمنا في السابق ان يواجه كل هذه
التحديات
والذكاء الخبره يعني عاملان اجتمعاها وهما
من صنعا قصه نجاح ترامب كرجل اعمال وايضا
عندما دخل عالم السياسي وهو الغريب عن هذا
العالم احتكاك مع قضيه القضاء التعامل مع
القضاء والاعلام يشير انه كلما تقدمت به
الخبره كلما زاد مضاء في استخدام الاسلحه
التي يتقنها على نحو متميز هذه القضيه مثل
ما تفضلتي يعني تماما هي اخف القضايا وقد
يبدو ان الامر وكانه خطا وقع فيه
الذي حتى الان تتسرب بعض الشائعات بانه
بدا يراجع نفسه بضغط من حزب الديمقراطي
لانه بالفعل وضع الجميع بور هذه المخالفات
كلها تتعلق بالبوكيبي بمعنى كيف تحفظ
القضايا ذات السجلات الماليه ولا يمكن باي
حاله من الاحوال بما سمي بالزومبي كيس هذه
التي بعثوا بها بعد موتها لا يمكن ان تؤثر
بشكل او باخر على عزيمه ترامب وفريقه
القانوني والسياسي من بعده بان يتقدم في
القضايا الاخرى التي هي ايضا محل تجازات
ولها وقتها حينئذ
بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا
جزيلا لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
بريطانيا تغرم تيك توك حوالي 16 مليون
دولار لاساءه استخدامه بيانات الاطفال
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه تلقى العائله
السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز رساله
من الرئيس الاماراتي الشيخ محمد بن زايد
تتعلق بالعلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
والشعبين الشقيقين تضمنت الرساله سبل دعم
العلاقات
وتعزيزا في مختلف المجالات
باتت فنلندا رسميا العضو 31 في حلف شمال
الاطلسي وقد سلم الرئيس الفنلندي
وثيقه الانضمام الى وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بحضور الامين العام لحلف الناتو
طبعا الانضمام فنلندا للنيتو اثاره حفيظه
موسكو موسكو قالت انها ستضطر الى اتخاذ
تدابير مضاده في سبيل وقف التهديد الذي
تمثله هذه الخطوه اكد بيان للخارجيه
الروسيه ان هذه الاجراءات قد تكون ذات
طبيعه عسكريه من اجل وقف ما اعتبرته
تهديدا للامن القومي الروسي جراء انضمام
فنلندا الى النيتو
من جانبه حمل وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه حمل
موسكو مسؤوليه توسع دول حلف الناتو قال ان
العدائيه الروسيه ستؤدي الى توسع النيتو
اكثر وان حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وراء
انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو دعونا نتابع
هذا يوم تاريخي لحظات تاريخيه نشهدها
بانضمام فنلندا الى حلف النيتو يرحب بها
كعضو في الحلف واريد ان اشير الى ان حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وراء انضمام فنلندا
الى حلف النيتو فالعدائيه الروسيه ستؤدي
الى توسع النيتو اكثر فاكثر نحن نسعى الى
تقويه التعاون بين حلف الناتو ودول جنوب
المحيط الهادئ
الى العراق حيث اعلن الرئيس الوزراء محمد
شياع السوداني رسميا عن اتفاق مؤقت مع
حكومه اقليم كردستان على استئناف تصدير
نفط الاقليم نت
قانون الموازنه واضح
في مواده ونصوصا التي وضعت والتي تعالج كل
المشاكل في ملف العلاقه بين حكومه
الاتحاديه وحكومه الاقليم مثل ما ذكرت
هناك اتفاق سياسي
وصوت عليه مجلس النواب
وضعنا ضمن اطار هذا الاتفاق السياسي
النصوص التي تعالج هذه المشاكل في قانون
الموازنه تصويت مجلس النواب ان شاء الله
على القانون سوف ينظم العلاقه بما يضمن
التوزيع العادل للثروه على كل المواطنين
سواء كان في داخل الاقليم او في باقي
المحافظات ضمن
المكتب المفوض المعلومات في بريطانيا عن
فرض غرامه على تطبيق تيك توك تقدر ب 16
مليون جنيه استرليني طبعا بسبب انتهاكات
متعدده لقانون حمايه البيانات من بينها
استخدام البيانات الشخصيه لاطفال اقل من
13 عاما وذلك دون موافقه الوالدين
الخامس انتهت شكرا المتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا